oh here we go Oh I found you ah I found
oh hello what the [ __ ] are you are you
doing in here
let's look out of here there it is okay
got it yes yes yes oh there was another
way oh there was the way at the boot um
oh okay I got it though ha ha ha hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to subnautica now things
got a little out of hand in the last
episode I will readily admit but I just
went down there in the dead of night to
not only get my CMOS back but also get
the last piece of the nuclear reactor
fragment so that I can build that in my
base but now I don't want to waste any
of you more you burned bed I can't talk
now I don't want to waste any more of
you guys as time so what I'm gonna do is
I'm going to speed through getting all
of the materials necessary to not only
build this nuclear reactor but also
provide me with enough titanium such
that I will not be such an idiot anymore
and I will not go down to the depth and
get what I don't have with what I don't
need where I don't need to go understand
so I'm gonna get into the future right
when in reality I have to form for a
while it's [ __ ] [ __ ] ok ok ok
welcome back one and all it is time
again to get into subnautica and go back
down into the depths and hopefully never
ever ever ever return ever again now I
don't know if that's true but all I know
is that I've got an inventory full of
titanium and enough materials to be able
to build a nuclear reactor and hopefully
with a nuclear reactor will be able to
use new
energy to power all of our nuclear needs
so once I get rid and stop being such a
fool and I don't want to be a fool I
want to be better than a fool I want to
be an above every school yeah I know
that we can get down and yes I I dunno I
dunno I dunno about the fact that I did
not see the de Ghazi base it was right
in front of me apparently I was just
being too much of a big bubble blowing
[ __ ] I'll be able to see it I'm just
trying to get one more piece of lead
before I get over there there we go
perfect you got it everything's falling
up my way everything's coming up
markiplier here so now that I got that
awesome almost dead act but now that I
got that I have enough material to be
able to go down here get in my base
again fix it all up nice and tight
get it right and tight and then be able
to build the nuclear reactor which I
need to build another room for that and
also not to forget that I need to put
the Locker names on there now
unfortunately I didn't save the list of
names I'm going to go back and get the
names from last episode that I did and
put them up there but for now I have put
this off for too long I'm going to do it
immediate own of course
ah okay you know what that's fine okay I
know the ominous music is kind of
coinciding with my own foolishness but
it's okay it's alright okay so I can be
as the more lockers now that's not
that's not corrected direction that
isn't that's weird
okay I don't wanna go with that is being
alright and not worry about it yeah okay
alright okay you know what it's alright
what what do I not have I'm out of power
for my builder I didn't even know the
thing could run out of power well I
don't have enough to make a battery of
all out of batteries oh oh oh come on
there's no acid mushrooms down here I
don't have a battery [ __ ] I am a goddamn
fool I can't build anything
I can't even build a battery charger
it's not a battery what I thought that I
didn't think of that did anybody think
of that no one thought of that no one
saw that coming
Wolk aye I didn't expect this in any
capacity I apologize I apologize I'm
just a bloody fool that's what I am I'm
a I'm a gosh-darn Who I am I am yes I am
so okay because good
oh wait before I do that what I can do
to be smart looking why would you just
Ram into that yeah that's what you're
supposed to do not ram into the pressure
barrier that's created by that pressure
[ __ ] I want to seem off and they're like
a common module storage module yeah I
think my CMOS baby needs a storage
module I'll go get more titanium while
I'm doing this black can't believe this
[ __ ] I can't believe this [ __ ]
dominant I'm going to do this because I
needed why not it does not have many
upgrades so matches well put the storage
module on it and then I'll be able to
take it out and I'll be [ __ ] back
with even more titanium and a fresh
battery pack see in a bit I suppose this
is what I promised this is what I
promised this is what I promised
no cheating it's the raw experience of
the game and that's what makes it fun Oh
fine hi hey I got it I got everything my
storage module is full to bursting it's
swollen with pride
it's swole with acid mushroom mostly and
a little bit of titanium salvaged I've
got everything that I need and we're
only 130 minutes into this recording
fine
that means more same time for you
because we are going down into Caesar -
gah see no matter what I'm accomplishing
that I just didn't know I was going to
run out of power but the good thing is
I've got oodles and Kaboodle's
of more
so that means I shouldn't run out for a
long time I don't know how many more
things I could possibly build out of
this son of a [ __ ] but I've got the
materials necessary to do it and that is
very important to know I've got what I
need to make my life easier and then go
home and then go see what's up with the
last place of the Ducati and finally put
some goddamn names on the goddamn
blockers so let's do all that all right
let me put some of this crap yeah get it
baby - babe I gotta make me up battery I
don't have the battery materials cuz I
put it back in here like an idiot
doodle ado let's unload all right got
that let's build a [ __ ] battery and
then we got to build a battery charge
because I've had the schematic for the
battery charger forever and I've just
been wasting batters either until ok oh
oh [ __ ] I got actually dude oh [ __ ]
what what am I added what oh I put away
my tights good
ah right yeah here ok oh that took a
while
hang on let me save on this one all
right okay all right the first name I'm
gonna point is everybody all of you guys
every single one of you out there
watching right now is on this locker
because not only was that last time that
everybody told me something that I
should have known but I was too stupid
to notice but now everybody said I
missed the hidden face cuz I'm a dummy I
am that's me that's me I'm a dummy
I'm the big old dummy do and I couldn't
see it when it was right in front of my
face because I was scared I was too busy
[ __ ] my pants to be able to see a
base in front me so congratulations
everybody you're now on the locker but
also m dot a dot d gam for ma mad gaming
said this is probably the most scared
and stressed at a game I've seen you
since vanish
your characters tombstone will be at the
bottom of the ocean edged with needs
needed more titanium well I've solved
that problem now because I've got so
much titanium but I know I'll run out
and thank you for being here all the way
back since the vanished days next up is
Jessica H for Jessica Hudson who said
I've never played subnautica but I'm
into horror movies so you constantly
[ __ ] yourself because of it makes me
want to buy it well if you hate the
ocean like I do then maybe this game is
not for you because otherwise I wouldn't
be playing this game because my god it's
[ __ ] terrifying literally all the
time there is not one moment when this
game is not terrifying to me it goes
halfway in between being like oh that's
so cool - aah aah
underwater ocean monsters because that's
all there is anyway I'm getting rid of
all the salvage that I got I'm turning
it into delicious titanium trying to
remember not to turn it into a goddamn
ingot like an idiot would which is
something that I've done before but I've
got enough ingots to be able to do what
I need to do
how much okay so that's all my salvage
if I put that I'll make this like the
titanium Locker like The Hurt Locker but
much less fun not that The Hurt Locker
was fun anyway you know I'm going to
take all that back I have no idea what
I'm talking about so it okay and you may
be thinking to yourself oh that's a lot
of titanium that you got there Marc
you're doing pretty well for yourself
well ha ha joke's on you that's not even
close to all the titanium that I got I'm
going to keep that Power Cell on me get
rid of this keep the lube dump the ion
Crystal's dump these bad batteries PLAs
is measuring sure ouch for cats good
baby boo not the water I need that right
now
[Music]
ok then I've got even more why
what spell titanium holy [ __ ] mark you
got it on it
the bag whoa a whole full scourge module
of all about titanium and I didn't
[ __ ] cheat at it neither uh I got a
headache
but I got it plus one plus one extra
titanium but unfortunately I do need
some titanium some it keeps them on me
because I am going to I probably need
more than that I'm gonna go out there
I'm gonna brave the horrible horrible
miss that is the ocean - so why is no
one why this one low that low doesn't
look low seems like it might be low now
whatever this is make this because I
know the bass isn't doing too good in
structural integrity so might as well
get a little more before we make another
attachment on it but I'm gonna make this
one multi-purpose room right
no can't build there yeah yeah yeah yeah
Karen I got it I got it you're always
worrying about me have I ever ever
gotten myself into trouble and not been
able to get out of it ever have a Oh
every time Oh Oh literally always Oh
well there must be some oh no no no
never no I've never once been able to
take myself out of situation but at
least I've got the necessary materials
to build a nuclear reactor you know one
of these little things
oh it's over here you know one of these
delightful monstrosity it's gonna pump
my entire base full fury
okay and and and and shabu ski
okay got it exercise caution when
handling radioactive materials in the
invent of exposure there's a risk that
the data on your PDA recording the
circumstances of your death will be
permanently erased whoa okay it's that
good or bad maybe nobody should know
that I was here knows do
horrible things so I need to get I need
to give you know it's odd that I have a
nuclear reactor in here when the nuclear
reactor killed the vast majority of my
fellow survivors here in the deep dark
ocean
oh well nah my door I just need to be
able to get a nuclear rod for that thing
and the only thing that I don't have in
that regard is the uranium I have one
more lead I was sure to get that before
I came back but all that is gonna have
to wait I know I can find uranium down
where the de gauzy is but I need to go
down there first now I've got enough
food I've got help I've got water I
don't have any of those spare things on
me I
I meant to build a filtration system but
I want to the whole I want to wait until
I actually have you know enough power
and and I'm pulling double-duty here
because I'm gonna go down into the
depths and I'm gonna go back go back in
the place that I hate I'm gonna go back
I gotta go back oh why do I have to go
back or even was it not here parently
jeez oh jeez Scoob yep
when I see you Karen take care of the
bass for me while I'm gone okay safe I
suppose oh wait I think I see it I think
I see it no yeah I do I do
it's right in front of me ah nope that's
a rock hey guy warper incoming holy [ __ ]
ah ah [ __ ] back Hill got a hit you oh
I've been told that you're not lethal
Roy you're still walking here or mine
you are okay alright we've got to be
here oh I see I see I see
ah I see it's right in front of my face
it was easy to miss because I was really
happy with where I was oh god oh god oh
god they really went all out with this
one huh oh [ __ ] you oh [ __ ] that
yeah leave me alone walk it out
leave me the [ __ ] alone I was told you
were non-lethal hmm okay so I gotta get
in there
so PDA in there this whole bunch of
stuff in there that I need oh boy oh I
will [ __ ] beat that [ __ ] out of you
you wanna [ __ ] fight breath Oh [ __ ]
I sit out of here yeah you better run
[ __ ] okay like I showed them
yeah I'm not to be trifled with alright
there is your art there was right here
game room do I have that I already have
that I don't need that I just need to
get the [ __ ] in here or not I do that ya
know don't access the upgrade okay sorry
in the air get in get in get in get in
get in get in we don't need you here
okay we got a PDA you're the PDA oh I
see them outside
Oh coffee vending machine okay how did
they have that bottle of booze okay this
is the way up I know that does wait up
let me get up oh I don't like the sound
of that
hey [ __ ] [ __ ] you oh I know you can't
hurt me but mmm whoo hey whoo oh [ __ ]
off you wanna [ __ ] on me ah I will [ __ ]
you up I will [ __ ] you up I will [ __ ]
you up the [ __ ] out of here [ __ ] you up
ah I'll punch you near jelly head how do
you like that huh you like it I got nah
I'm gonna [ __ ] you up
get ground Wow [ __ ] dead are we are
we dead are we dead oh we twitching dead
corpse that's right get the [ __ ] out of
here I got tried to mess with me taught
bullhorn hold that's what the pole you
get my ass
I think detached open okay cool Oh an
aquarium in there we'll get the legs
okay nothing in there okay I can go down
but let me check all the observatories
and whatnot
whoo there's another PDA here I'm gonna
I'm gonna look at all these in a bit
one they have more time to think about
it okay okay another one their lab
equipment I'm going use that towards
coal orange artifact orange artifact
that's weird
okay do I need this lab equipment why
would I need this I don't need that I'll
take it anyway I guess scanner room
fragment I already have that okay I
think that's absolutely everything I do
not see anything else besides no that's
nothing there's nothing in there I got
the PDAs I've got everything I need
let's get the [ __ ] out of here get the
[ __ ] outta here
okay I believe the exit is this way yeah
at least I know I can beat the [ __ ] out
of those guys with my wicked hooks my
haymakers were covered in hot and heavy
I [ __ ] come on I hate that please look
you guys you guys may have some
understanding that I hate the ocean but
I have learned in my time in subnautica
especially being of the mind where I'm
just here alone
and I know it's a game but I [ __ ] I
can't deal I cannot deal with that
uh-uh I hate it I [ __ ] hate it non
exaggeration not a joke not a [ __ ]
goof it's just this is not fun not fun
down there not fun even if I can beat
the [ __ ] out of a crab squid which is
what that is
um we are home baby I'm home
Karen oh [ __ ] get away okay so I've got
lab equipment for some reason Jessica
can you hold onto this for me and I've
got a orange artifact I've never seen
into orange artifact before I didn't
need one okay so to gauzy logs databank
not logged in Bank data downloads pegasi
survivors logs seven stop it both of you
were sick what how you've been coughing
right feeling itchy
yeah the suit biometrics would have
warned us it's something new
spit it out then are we gonna throw up
our insides dissolve in the slime what I
don't know if I can isolate the bacteria
in our blood then I could test its
effect on our live specimens and if it
turns them inside out you got to fixture
that none - this time no you have my
full faith son sound of hatch closing
CPU Margaret maida has boarded the
habitat what are you so happy about
maida hey kid
I brought you something that'll
Leviathan towed it home on the back of
the sub you killed it it's still
breathing I was about to finish the job
pass me that hardened knife are you out
of your mind you brought that thing here
what if others come you rather it got
curious and came of its own accord or
gotten messed up and dragged here when
we get off this planet I'm gonna drag
you through every court in the damn
Empire Oh stow it chief the kid needs
specimens for his research I'm the one
bringing them home Bart teller
tell her I'm right you're both wrong
Margaret I can't find out how these
creatures resist the bacteria if you
kill them all pump them full of
transfuser serums it often oblige and
coming in alive what do you expect don't
speak to him like that
father the outcomes no better if we hole
up in here and don't go outside we have
to find a middle way there's no
compromise not while she's on my sea
bass your sea bass I'm going outside
aren't torgul is left the habitats
barred it's dangerous damn it boy I know
you can hear me chief
chief get off the radio and put on your
helmet what brace sound of habitat
rupturing
water pouring in so they got attacked by
a Leviathan they did survive a long time
with the disease but they in the end got
attacked by a Leviathan
probably because Margaret [ __ ]
brought one home why why would you do
that okay but I need to make uranium I
got a ton of that I've got a ton of that
actually I've got more in here I only
need the one right now but I just want
to get this stuff out of here because
doodly-doo because I can okay thank you
mr. Fisher you are good Andrew great
middle of you okay advanced materials
uranium I'm gonna make a uranium rod let
me just make sure I didn't dump any more
lead in here I got both lead okay can I
make another one nope it's not in food
uranium rod is not food
and then BAM okay so I got two so
there's a maximum before that you can
put in but now that I have this I should
this should work right just yeah yeah
yeah yeah look at that power I mean it
doesn't look like it's doing a whole lot
but the power shooting up yeah yeah I've
got power oh I've got so much power and
that means that I can make a water
filtration system that separates water
and salts with that right bear got
plenty of water it's gonna make water up
for me I'm gonna have plenty of water to
go I'm gonna be good I'm gonna be so
good
I'm gonna be the best how long is this
how long does a bummer egg been just
sitting in my my mr. Fisher's inventory
oops but this is good this is good
because now that I've got more than
enough power to offset that and then
this only has enough space so it's not
going to go on forever just making
endlessly
it's gonna make just enough so that I
can do that oh I can make one more
uranium rod I can
lots of power okay
and the Boop okay got that that's gonna
make me up some water real quick and
then ah
boo-ki okay yes oh that's so good
that's so good I've got so much power
yeah I'm doing it I'm doing it okay so
anyway it's been a bit of a long haul
for this episode for me anyway you guys
are probably seeing the accelerated
version of it but it's been a long haul
for me and I managed to do it so I'm
very happy with where we are right now
I'm hoping that this gives me water
before I run out of water but if I need
more water I'll just go eat some fruit I
suppose but either way thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
for believing in me this whole time
which I'm sure you all did without a
doubt in your mind about my survival
chances yeah thank you Karen so thank
you everybody so much for watching keep
the comments flowing I now have the
means with which to make lockers again
and as I make them I'm going to write in
names and fill in some of the names that
I miss them less thank you everybody so
much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye
[Music]